rosa muy buen día aquí en Guatemala las
lluvias no han cesado Desde la madrugada
De este lunes territorio guatemalteco
donde ya ingresó la tormenta Julia
degradada como depresión tropical de
acuerdo con el Centro Nacional de
Huracanes de los Estados Unidos sin
embargo Aunque este fenómeno
metereológico sus vientos ya hayan
descendido a 56 kilómetros por hora el
nivel de precipitaciones preocupa porque
ya hay decenas de municipios
incomunicados deslaves Ríos inundados
Por lo cual fue activado el protocolo de
evacuaciones están canceladas las clases
y el sistema de atención a desastres
está pendiente de lo que pueda llegar a
ocurrir este lunes en cuanto al Salvador
de donde proviene la tormenta por la
costa del Pacífico la Policía Nacional
de este país ha anunciado la muerte de
dos personas en un municipio del oriente
luego del derrumbe de varios muros y al
parecer una tercera estaría también
sepultada Honduras por su parte que es
un país centroamericano por donde no
atravesó la tormenta directamente ha
sido ha resultado uno de los más
afectados
riadas intensas desbordamientos de ríos
provocaron el ahogamiento de tres
personas centenares de familias
afectadas y Se presume además Fuentes
extraoficiales dicen que una embarcación
de siete personas estaría desaparecida
vaya Andrés y por otro lado Julia golpeó
a Nicaragua como huracán de categoría 1
antes de degradarse como usted decía
atormentada Tropical Cuál es el balance
en ese país
en Nicaragua la información que se
obtiene es muy reducida sin embargo de
acuerdo con la vicepresidenta Rosario
Murillo quien funge como la directora de
comunicaciones del país no hubo saldo de
víctimas mortales Eso sí más de 1.500
familias afectadas 70 Ríos desbordados
3000 casas destruidas y
300 árboles caídos Lo que sí es que el
norte y el sur del Caribe nicaragüense
se encuentra todavía completamente
incomunicado dado que se dañó el tendido
eléctrico y la red de telefonía y se
espera a lo largo del día que se
obtengan noticias de este sitio
bluefields por donde ingresó Julia
convertida como huracán de categoría 1